c'est dans cette ferme isolée à
magny-cours que s'est déroulé le drame
vers 22 heures hier soir un homme
pénètre dans la propriété
ils tirent sur trois personnes alertés
par un voisin les gendarmes se rendent
sur place ils découvrent deux personnes
tuées
la propriétaire de l'exploitation une
femme d'une soixantaine d'années est
l'un de ses amis
une troisième victime grièvement blessée
à la tête et transportée à l'hôpital de
nevers il s'agirait de l'ex-mari de
l'occupante des lieux
de son côté le meurtrier présumé a pris
la fuite en voiture
il est activement recherché par les
gendarmes de la nièvre
un hélicoptère de la section aérienne de
dijon a été appelé en renfort
selon des voisins le suspect serait un
ancien associé de la propriétaire décédé
il pourrait avoir mal vécu la fin de
leur collaboration
ce matin le tireur présumé était
toujours en fuite et activement
recherchés